fear is the most powerful
most primal motivator in our little
dinosaur brains
[Music]
the show pays homage to the classic
horror films of the past in
our visual style in our approach towards
more
practical horror effects
so much of what we do on the show is
practical
so much of it is happening live you
don't have to imagine
that you're seeing a giant chest opening
because it's there right in front of you
it's scary
we really go back to the roots of what
makes horror horror which is the human
element
what happens when as a human being you
let the demon inside you take over
and make you do something that you
didn't think you were capable of
that's the real scare i couldn't stop
myself
when i first saw beth transform
into the demon that's inside her i
remember being super terrified the way
that she looked at you
it was dead i am the scary moment on
this show
it's the potential for violence
that's truly terrifying when you
actually see it
there's something in your mind that can
cope with it but it's
feeling the potential that is so
frightening we've had some talented
directors
orchestrate some very fun jump scares in
the show
the difference between a jump scare and
a real scare for me
at jump scares which you see on tv in
the moment
that comes in a cut that makes you go up
works every time but a real scare
is what keeps you up at night and it
doesn't have to be a monster or a gory
image
it can be a moment between two people
where someone just says something
really awful and it just sits there and
resonates in your brain
your mother
hated you going head-to-head with beth
i was beyond petrified
it's an epic struggle against forces
that are
greater than anything that a human can
deal with there is a real life
horror to some of the stuff we talk
about that's
real fear